for the people whose first life hacks
this is this is what we're here for it's
the peak artist if you think these are
[ __ ] imagine how bad the ones that
didn't get on here are
in case people at home are wondering why
I'm in an unfamiliar setting many of you
may not have seen me here before this is
my house in Newcastle and this is the
studio that probably 350 or 400 episodes
of the podcast has been done in and I'm
back for Johnny's wedding this week so
I've flown back from America survived
the flight all went well uh and I'm here
so the next few episodes that you're
going to see will be with me in this
kind of surroundings also if you're not
familiar with life hacks it's been a
little while since we did one this was
the first ever series that we did on the
show and it's continued snow this will
be like the 20th episode we do a little
round table we've come up with how to
make a great toasted sandwich or a new
exercise desk or whatever else we get
into and then one of them puts it
Forward suggests why they think it's a
great idea then the other two either
tear it to pieces or immediately go on
Amazon and buy it so if there's anything
that you like the sound of that we go
through today there'll be links to all
of the stuff that we talk about in the
show notes below and that's pretty much
it anything missed
just that normally what happens at this
point is you hot potato me and I have to
say the first one well it's interesting
because I did actually bring a potato
which you'll find if you open iMessage
there is a potato in there uh Johnny
please give us your first life hack yeah
it is it's microwaved almost so hot that
I'm tempted to throw it back but I'll
I'll I'll keep a hold of it good so my
first one
is I think a symptom of the fact that
I'm now
over 30 getting older and clearly
the various social media platforms know
this and they've started targeting me
with a lot of skin care products I don't
know whether you two get this
yeah yeah not loads but maybe not Chris
because Chris is just ageless always
beautiful Benjamin
um so there's a there's this brand
that's been like over and over and over
again and I've just been ground down
over time it's called Lumen have you
seen this before
no you haven't seen it wow it's so weird
isn't it because in my world it's like
what you haven't seen it yeah so I see
it like every day so it's a it's like
they try and get you on a subscription
but they have this cool thing where you
you go onto that website you answer some
questions because that it's something
that you've said to me before Chris like
use a moisturizer and all that sort of
stuff and I don't really put any effort
into it and I kind of want to but I
don't really know where to begin and it
all looks really expensive and quite
intimidating so you go through and go
through there like questionnaire they
ask you questions about your skin types
and all that sort of stuff and then they
just send you a little kit with loads of
little tubs in there really like
aesthetic and nice and they smell nice
and they feel nice and I've been using
those for a while they send the same set
of little tubs I don't want to think
about that I don't want to think about
that I could say that the quiz the
entire quiz is just a show and everyone
receives the same bundle of products
that it's all just a facade so make you
feel like you're getting a really nice
customized Medical
in various forms
okay so what's what's your current
skincare care routine then
how long have you got I'm just joking
it's not that complicated so there's a
there's like a face wash like a charcoal
face wash why charcoals in it I don't
know but it it feels like it's great and
like there's some secret mechanism to
that charcoal face wash is a anti-aging
moisturizer and then there's a charcoal
scrub this is starting to sound like the
opening scene of American Psycho this is
a charcoal scrub that you use like a
couple of times a week
which does have this weird way of just
taking the first layer of your skin off
so that feels a bit strange so it's
those three things and you rotate them
and there's different packs that you get
sent depending on your skin type and the
like the sort of skin you have like the
where they've had spots or things like
that in the past so
I found it pretty good I've enjoyed the
experience how much is it going to get
it again
good question
it varies so it varies depending on the
pack you get but it's like it's also in
dollars but like 30 to 50 dollars for a
set that they say will last you for a
month but you can stretch that out like
I miss days yeah I'm not you're supposed
to use it twice a day
I don't know twice I know everyone feels
excessive they also have actually the
next video on the channel like hey guys
welcome back to my channel uh but don't
forget to like And subscribe I'm gonna
go through my five-step morning routine
with my skin care as an entrepreneur
that's what I could see you doing
while this video is happening if you're
on YouTube that's the Lumen uh so you
just click click on that I believe it's
l-u-m-i-n
got you because Lou men is that not the
metabolism breathalyzer thing
correct perilously close that's what I
thought you were on about at first oh
man I I said it ages ago every person
needs but you probably need something
more than just a moisturizer but the
sooner that you can start moisturizing I
think the better find one that works
with your skin and just use it so hey
I'm I'm down I will I will check it out
Yusuf what have you got
I would love to show you this one but I
didn't touch any of the equipment around
me it would be perilous yes to do that
because I have a grounding issue and it
could cause the camera to turn off but I
have or had an Alcove in my room
a little niche you could call it of uh
of wall that I would had a bar in there
and hanging some clothes and a pile of
kind of mismatched drawers and that kind
of thing thinking there's no way that
I'm going to be able to get a wardrobe
that fits exactly that
and then I found the Ikea custom
wardrobe service
so you can book in
like a zoom call with someone in an Ikea
Swedish outfit
Swedish with like a blurred background
and their ears colored in with with
crayon
and they just talk you through
measurements and they build you a
wardrobe custom to the space and you can
choose what type of storage you want in
it so now it's it's added a lot of
perceived space to my room because it's
got mirrored door and it's incredible
just feel the room just feels so much
less stressful for clarity you were on a
Skype call or a zoom call with a person
from Ikea with a tape measure and they
were coaching you through how to measure
the wall this happened
yeah
do they do anything else apart from just
like get the tape measure and hold one
end of it and is there more to it than
that yeah so they say hello my my name
is
I am calling from Ikea
can you please tell me the width depth
and height of your thing okay here's the
and they get a digital mock-up and they
share screen and they go like okay would
you like drawers up to here and how many
have you got lots of trousers or have
you got lots of jackets and they help
you to design a customer that's pretty
cheap
preset well obviously you pay for the
Wardrobe yes the you're paying for the
world it's free yeah is the Wardrobe
more expensive I presume it is
it was about 550 pounds in total God yes
that's a as as wardrobes go
that's pretty expensive
it's probably cheap for a custom fit
wardrobe though yep also yeah like that
depends on the lens you look at it
through isn't it but yeah
maybe more than a more than I was
expecting but
sounds like you're very happy with it so
I think I think the mirrored doors are
what adds to the price like if you've
got plain doors it would be like 300
quid and what's that called Ikea custom
what how do people get it uh I think if
you just search Ikea custom wardrobe Pax
is what it's called Pax all right lovely
do they do other custom stuff
yeah
let's pull Storage Solutions it's pretty
nice right this one has been requested
an awful lot because I made the error of
bringing up a product on an episode with
Balaji uh and then I I didn't describe
precisely which one it was which sent
people into a tailspin so this is my new
cycling desk which I got
after learning a lot about Zone 2 cardio
and the benefits of zone two Zone 2
being pretty gentle for most people 110
to maybe 135 BPM heart rate stuff could
hold a conversation with a little bit of
breathing in between basically that's
where that's where zone two is Andrew
human's a huge fan of it you need to be
doing between 120 and 180 minutes per
week if you can it is train slow to run
fast is the strategy behind it that it
helps you to train in an aerobic base
which then gives you more of a ceiling
until you need to go anaerobic all this
sort of stuff uh problem is that zone 2
sucks dick it is such an unbelievably
boring way to train unless you're into
like trail running or kind of aggressive
hiking it's actually quite difficult to
find a pace on your feet
to to move at that because it's not a
jog a jog is gonna at least for me is
gonna put me into the 140s but a walk is
going to keep me around about 100 so I'm
in this kind of dead zone in between the
two it's also supposed to be very good I
mean you guys could probably
stress test this once I'm done really
good for fat loss apparently if you were
to continue to do it uh anyway
I was talking to some of the boys in the
uh autistic degenerates group chat I've
got from Austin and asking their
solutions for it and a bunch of them had
treadmill desks that you can slide
underneath one of the problems that you
have there is that you're moving up and
down which actually makes it a little
bit more difficult to type it's good for
uh calls if you've got lots of
conferencing apart from the fact that
you're obviously walking which is a bit
of a dick move to the other person long
story short I spent
an entire evening very very carefully
analyzing the difference between every
different cycling desk that I could find
on Amazon and I ended up you find
yourself down like a weird Rabbit Hole
of the internet like how did I get here
oh dude yeah I was looking I was looking
at the difference between the exoputic
exawork 2000i
and the uh the 1000i so the one that I
ended up going for was the Bluetooth
folding exercise desk bike with 24
workout programs and a free app
um that being said
it's one of my favorite purchases of
this year it is absolutely fantastic the
particular one that I went for is a
little bit more
um chunky it's a little bit more well
built than the one that was below it
unfortunately the fact that it's got
Bluetooth that's what it's sold on but
what you actually want to buy it for is
it's got a bigger backrest it's got a
bigger seat they've got this really
special
um airflow seat thing a lot of the
criticisms of the other ones were that
after half an hour it was very painful
on your bum so I wanted one that I knew
I could do a long session on obviously
if you're trying to accumulate 180
minutes on something per week that's a
good bit of time sat on something if
it's uncomfortable it's gonna suck uh
it's a magnetic drive so it's completely
silent when you're turning over so if
you are on calls or if you're doing
anything else no one can hear uh on top
of that the magnetic resistance which is
linked to your phone because everything
needs Bluetooth including your exercise
desk uh the magnetic resistance if you
turn it up to level 24 which is the
highest it goes is uh like a 10 gradient
it is unbelievably hard there's no way
you could work whilst doing that it's
like a Max effort rpe 8 cycle uh long
story short it links in with your whoop
strap so it'll broadcast your heart rate
from your whoop strap to the app and
track distance calories uh all of that
stuff linked in with this it'll give you
totally total calories burned and total
time spent on the bike per week it'll
give you that in the app as well so I'm
actually quite glad that I did get the
one with Bluetooth and I think in a week
last week I ended up accumulating 3 000
calories burned just while I was sat
turning over answering emails uh taking
a few calls I do find it quite hard to
do anything more cognitively demanding
than scheduling and simple email replies
even a a slightly complex phone call
where I'm having to do a bit of
cognition is is a bit much
but all in all really really happy with
it it was 350 so the one that I'm
talking about is the only one that you
could get I think you can only get this
in America which is unfortunate there is
an equivalent one in the UK which has a
backrest to it as well and I bought my
dad that for his birthday it was the
closest one that I could get there's
only one in the UK that has a backrest
that's the one to go for main reason
being that you've got a slightly more
sort of
rather than an upright seated position
you're a little bit more sat back you
know like those the ones that you'll get
in uh David Lloyd's gym and the the foot
pedals are away from you and you kind of
sat down in his handles either side it's
a little bit more like that uh if you
want to get more Zone 2 cardio in or if
you spend a lot of time working from
home and you want to get a bit more
calorie expenditure
is what to go for
I'm really glad that you've guinea pigs
that because I I've seen those and I
always thought ah it's one of those
things that could end up becoming a a
new like drying rack in your house
so it's great to know that it doesn't
interrupt calls and because you're right
like zone two is very hard to achieve on
your feet because it's kind of an uphill
walk and you you can't really design a
route where you're only walking uphill
unless you live in Edinburgh where it's
like an Esha painting and everything's
uphill so yeah it's brilliant I think
I'm gonna go I'm sold yeah I'm sold on
one
yeah they I honestly I I it's rare
because you're totally right it's the
sort of thing that you would end up
looking at research and getting excited
about buying and then going [ __ ] you
shouldn't have got that but
it kind of the only way that this could
go wrong is if it's not sufficiently
comfortable or if there was some issue
with the biomechanics of how it fits
your particular frame because when they
add Bluetooth it's like oh it's got the
wrong Bluetooth version and it can't
connect to the thing or yeah
even with that they have foolproof that
as well because there's a l LCD screen
um that allows you to do that now it
might be worth uh everybody emailing
exoputic extra work and seeing if
they'll ship to the UK because yeah that
is the one crowd Source the pressure
yeah that being said though the version
that I got my dad was 120 quid
it's 120 pounds for this and it's got
the top and it's got a wrist rest so
that you can actually lean on it a
little bit while you're working away
and what's it missing the Bluetooth
piece it's a basically a completely
different it's the same looking
construction but I can't vouch for the
seat quality I can't vouch for the build
I can't vouch for you know most of the
most of the stuff but I think 120 quid
drops it into like
a level where you buy it and if it
doesn't work it's like not like oh God
where you know you start moving towards
500 quid it starts to get like a you
better use it honest I'm surprised it
was the the low side of 500 quid I
thought it would be in the thousands
yeah me too which makes me worried
because I think 120 quid is it going to
be rickety like could you be halfway
through an email and you just fall off I
think this is not a demand for them yet
yeah I bet in in a couple well after
this episode it has a little well
there'll be a link I'll try I'll find
the one uh for the UK that I got my dad
and I'll put that in the show notes and
I'll put the exerpeutic extra work 2000i
and I'll throw that in the in the show
notes as well but yeah and put the email
address of the founder so that we can
all yeah we can all Hammer them so you
can harass them I think if you can't
find one or if you end up finding that
the the version that you get is
uncomfortable the general rule of some
form of exercise
bike treadmill thing at your desk for
doing uh working it makes emails I
genuinely look forward to doing my
emails because I get two amounts of
satisfaction off the other side of it
I'm like yeah it's I got to do 60
Minutes of sitting down and replying to
people but I'm gonna burn
400 calories 500 maybe 450 calories in
that hour
pretty good pretty good kind of a nice
way to batch it as well right it's like
you've created the time unless you're
just going to cycle indefinitely like
back when you stop like by the time I
stop cycling I should have cleared my
emails yep quite a nice rule to have
pretty good uh right Johan what you got
right I've never seen you that excited
about a life hack by the way this is my
favorite list this is my favorite list
that of ones that I've done
okay mine just feels so [ __ ] in
comparison but here we go
um
so that so this is surreal cereal
so it is a cereal brand called surreal
s-u-r-r-e-a-l right now there's there's
loads of these cropping up now like when
I first found these it's because
Tim Ferriss mentions a brand at the
start of his podcast I did for a while I
can't remember the name of it but it's
like a low calorie yes low calorie low
carb technically I think keto friendly
cereal a lot of big names behind it
um and I was like that sounds class you
look very nice it's very yeah I bet you
can only get it or you could only get it
in the US so ship internationally now
but it's kind of it's well quite pricey
yeah so this stuff's not cheap either
um but this at the time was the only
brand in the UK that I could find that
was reasonably priced that looked nice
so I ordered like I ordered like eight
boxes
um yeah
um it's really like it's it's the same
sort of thing as like a grenade bar
right a grenade bar to a Mars bar you
can kind of tell that it's higher in
protein and lower in sugar and all that
sort of stuff but if you're mixing it
with things like a cavag
like a white chocolate pudding thing
whatever what are they it's not pudding
it's not yogurt so you know what I mean
or into something it's just great
because it's like it's the crunch of
cereal without the calories of cereal
and I really enjoy it so what are the
best flavors that you got
so there is one which is I think peanut
butter which
obviously I couldn't get otherwise I
would if I'd go to hospital
um so I tried chocolate which is not
that nice
normally my rulers always get chocolate
flavor because it's always flavored with
chocolate not in this case the like the
sugar like the the Frosted
um one is the nicest one by far and away
so like the Frosty's equivalent
um I don't really know what it's I don't
think it's not coated with sugar but
it's coated with something that tastes
like sugar so
it's great surreal surreal well the
I would like to just highlight this
little nugget of wisdom that Johnny has
just dropped on the side there of always
go for chocolate flavor
rather than something mad I think that's
been a previous life hack yeah I think
it is possibly because flavored with the
chocolate probably except if it's some
kind of Health product where they they
try and Jimmy it by saying it's low carb
or whatever because then they'll end up
using like carob extracts rather than
actual cocoa
funnily enough I think there's no cocoa
in the
um exactly as you call it in the
chocolate yeah well I mean I think any
anything now
the food industry is catching up to what
Bros have been Jerry rigging for the
last decade and a half you know when
you'd make protein pancakes but they
would be awful because you would have
just poured some impact way over the top
of Pancakes and gone well this this
surely can't make any difference and
they come out and it tastes terrible and
it looks terrible and the consistency is
awful and it's all powdery and stuff but
yeah I mean magic spoon I've had that a
good bit in America and high high
protein cereal here's the other thing as
well that I loved about it it's not just
the high protein high protein thing's
good but it's the reduction in the
amount of sugar and carbs that you get
in it because I find the sort of size of
bowl of cereal that I imagine you eat
Jonathan will be similar to the ones
that me and used to do which is an
industrial sized bowl and it's not a 30
gram serving yeah is it yeah yeah who
eats that's that's completely insane
when you do that I get usually about an
hour afterward I get a bit of a slump I
can feel inflammation going a little bit
and I get that sort of tingly feeling
around the out and I'm just like ah my
sugars like my blood sugar I imagine
your forearms look like they're very
burst yeah very turgid uh Yusef my suit
for Johnny's wedding is having to get
sized up exclusively because it doesn't
fit on the forearms literally
used to pinch pinch a centimeter of
material and I couldn't do it I couldn't
get anything like the skin of a balloon
it's we've described it as one of those
old water snakes that you used to get
from the pound shop
right it's a real cereal uh is there
there must be some sort of discount
introy scenario is there I'm not sure I
can have a look I don't think there is
um someone will be able to snide go on
the website I'm sure you'll be able to
snide it right Yusuf we got
so I've actually been doing some
thinking about the the way that I
broadly categorize life hacks and
I've kind of landed on a categorization
system that's basically physical and
digital so I've given you a physical one
what follows is a digital
is it Alfred
so it is to appify a website
so we've probably done this the three of
us but most people don't know that if
there's a website that you frequently
visit and you'd prefer and it's got you
know mobile friendly but you'd prefer to
be able to access it from your home
screen press the little share button
which looks like a square with an arrow
coming out of it or it'll look like a
like a phallic symbol if you're using
Android
um
and
you can then say add to home screen
and it'll generate what's functionally
an app
on your home screen so avoids you having
to go like into Safari and find the
thing or press on your favorites so we
do that with our program that we uh that
we teach coaches to
to package their services online with
and you can do it with any website
I'm writing thinking it at least on
iPhone it displays in a different way as
well it goes into kind of a full screen
a more full screen mode I think yeah it
doesn't show the address bar so it just
gives you
our screen experience yeah so I mean if
you use a website for coaching for what
your coach sends you for programming and
stuff like that I mean
everybody needs to be using I'm pretty
sure that that was exactly what I used
to use it for before romwon had an app I
remember that I was using that for the
precise same thing
it's just like a and it's also like
bookmarks you frequently you visit it's
such a simple way of having them on your
home screen yeah even if it wasn't the
increased
screen size just the ease of access
hitting on the home screen yeah yeah
that is nice uh right okay so this was
sent in by Eric Jorgensen the guy that
wrote uh the navalmanac and you guys may
be familiar with this
Pro tip if you cancel your Zoom
subscription they'll offer you 30 off
your renewal price immediately
I didn't know that
takes 30 seconds
I'm not sure how I feel about that as a
as a business model because they're then
rewarding that well that they're
penalizing loyal customers aren't they
retention's the name of the game baby
you know this collection I wonder how I
wonder how long we'll keep that running
for maybe well I mean something tells me
that even the volume of people that are
going to go and try and cancel their
Zoom subscription after this is going to
be a dent in do you remember during the
pandemic when Chinese a Chinese company
called Zoom
their stock price increased by 150 due
to people buying the wrong Zoom company
yeah
incredible
that would have been a scary moment for
the uh the CEO and the board members
[Laughter]
I remember hearing a similar thing with
delivering delivery was new where you
could like
I never did this full disclaimer but you
could when I think someone on the on
this podcast told me about it when the
delivery arrived you could say one of
the items were available in the order
and if it was under 50 pounds they would
instantly give you your money back
without investigating so James James who
used to work for us this still works by
the way James who worked for us cycled
between deliveroo uh and ubereats using
the exact same thing ordering lunch off
one dinner off the other when it arrived
something's wrong with my order what's
wrong items are missing which items all
items make sure that his order was under
50 pounds and they would just instantly
refund him he's now banned from
deliveroo for life he can't they they
won't give him an account stealing from
restaurants anymore in sequence because
it comes off I'm pretty sure delivery
just pay it straight out
um but yeah he accumulated weeks and
weeks and weeks of food doing this fill
at steak for lunch yes sir correct yes
how imaginary delivery pay the
restaurant it'll be double delivery
that's losing out yes I would have
thought so I think but yeah if you go to
cancel your Zoom subscription they'll
offer you 30 off your renewal price and
it takes 30 seconds thank you Eric
Johnny
it's you
that was I know that was you yes
goodness me
um
so this one
I didn't think was a hack but I've
mentioned it to a few people and each
person I mentioned it to hadn't heard of
it
so I'm hoping I don't get absolutely
shot down with this so if you have
Amazon Prime
and you order something which is next
day delivery
once you've ordered it
you can go into orders like my orders
the order and then select just change it
from free next day to free Rush shipping
and then it just arrives
a couple of hours later instead of the
following day
so there are certain things that come
that just have the availability to be
for no extra charge to just arrive
before 10 pm
when before editing the order
you can do it after
ordering it sometimes it's available
before editing yes and there are some
things where it'll say before 10 pm but
on quite a few things
if there's next day available there is
also a rush available so I have things
arrive it's like a red class and and
light like the panic button that goes
off in the warehouses when someone does
that and they go oh quick and the guy
like runs over and stuffs into his
pocket and like gets on his scooter and
flies over to your house I I've had
stuff delivered from Amazon using this
process that it it arrived in less time
than it would have taken me to go out to
a shop and buy it and come back to the
house what's the quickest that
something's arrived do you think from
order to arrival
within 90 minutes
for like food based things so I had a
bag of coffee beans delivered 90 minutes
after I ordered them
wow so you typically didn't know about
that so I'm that's a big one like I use
that all the time really it's so good
yeah what how when do you order stuff
that you need within hours
it's little it's little things like um
whiteboard pens batteries golf balls
yeah like things that things that I'm
like oh [ __ ] I really could do with
those by tomorrow morning
yeah I know don't need to wait till
tomorrow morning by 10 p.m today yeah
America has uh some of that they don't
call it Russia over there but where you
can designate a time today do you want
it from Seven until 11 11 until three or
three until seven today and uh that's
nice that's pretty enjoyable on Amazon
yeah
I'm still waiting for drone delivery
there's so in Austin at the moment there
are these little robot fridges it looks
like a little robot fridge and there's
some in the UK have these been around
Milton Keynes right yeah so it's a
little robot that's got food in it it
does food delivery and it it stops at
the side of roads and waits for traffic
to go by and the light to change and it
just delivers your food
and it's Amazon Amazon no no something
else some other service Amazon do you
have those shops where like there's no
staff in the shop and you go in no yeah
you go and just pick stuff up and it
knows what you picked up and it bills
you feel really uncomfortable wouldn't
it there's a bunch of videos online uh
trying to shoplift in Amazon go
like both going in in the same time or
something like that I don't I haven't
seen them I've just seen them pop up on
my right free Rush shipping after
ordering on Amazon Prime dude I like
that especially if it's especially if
it's not available so the saving money
thing is is good but if it's not
available when you go on and yet it is
available upon editing that's a genuine
hack this is why for the people whose
first life hacks this is this is what
we're here for it's the peak artist back
end
time like it only works in one millionth
of a of a times like operation and yet
we're very excited about it this is what
you guys don't see is the thousands of
life hacks that didn't make it to this
tables if you think these are [ __ ]
imagine how bad the ones that didn't get
on here are
it's the things that we're we're too
embarrassed to bring up yes because
they're so weird that's the real life
hacks the Viagra Hammer that didn't work
yeah after after hours list
right Yusuf what you got
this is one that I originally was made
aware of by Tim ferriss's mate who loves
foiling and goes on to his podcast and
talks to him about foiling for three
hours I forgot his name so it's actually
based on
a modality of psychotherapy known as
internal family systems and the idea is
that you are not a single personality a
single unit of Consciousness you are
multiple sub personalities that are
frozen in time at different stages of
your life depending on
what happened in your life and they run
certain scripts in response to stimuli
that you're exposed to
and so they have different roles in your
psyche and they are to protect you or to
keep you safe or happy or whatever it is
and so it's a technique for if your mind
is rushing and you're you're lying in
bed for example and you've got loads of
stuff going on
is to do the board member exercise the
boardroom
so you imagine that you are at the head
of a table you're sat at the boardroom
you're wearing the suit
and then there's loads of different
versions of you sat around the table
and the these versions of you represent
different domains of your life so you
could have the finance version of you
that's got the the accountant's hat and
the cigar and you've got the fitness
version of you that's in the gym shark
um sort of cute onesie thing and you've
got the work version of you that's in
your work gear and all these different
things and you just go around the table
and you say right
everyone else shut up you tell me what's
on your mind you've got five minutes
everyone has to stop and listen
and then you let them speak and then
when they're done you go okay are you
finished yeah brilliant move on to the
next one and just work your way around
and it sounds silly but it is the most
relaxing thing that you could do because
you squeeze the lemon of all these like
little voices that are trying to be
heard in your mind but
aren't being given the full air time
and afterwards your mind is so quiet
you're just like
oh and it lasts for
like the last time I did it I think I
had probably about 48 Hours of Deep
Quiet afterwards wow
it's not like a daily thing
you wouldn't do it every day
or would you yeah you can do okay it
depends how deep you want to go
did you mentioned that this is a good
technique for when your mind is feeling
a bit of overwhelm specifically
yeah very good for that uh I think the
the ultimate use case is if you're you
know when you're lying in bed and for
some reason or you feel like you feel
like you've had too much caffeine or
whatever and your mind's just going you
can't even make sense of all the the
voices and I think people are afraid of
this kind of technique because they
think oh well I've not got multiple
personality disorder I'm not psychotic
but I think if you can just accept that
like just humor the voices inside for a
moment and don't worry about
that as a as a thing I want I do want to
highlight up front that uh
past performance may not be an indicator
of future profits with someone like
Yusef because of the amount of time that
he's spent meditating I do feel like all
of this Sedona Method that you've done
releasing different strategy I think
that this probably enables you to maybe
get
disproportionate returns
possibly yeah like you you know you have
to it does require concentration and
there is also a sense of like you've got
to just kind of
even like when you start doing it you'll
be like oh this is silly I'm just making
it up here but that's okay because if
you're making it up like it's what what
comes to mind came to mind for a reason
so that's still valid how many sessions
did you need to do before it didn't feel
silly
to be honest on the first one
because I was just like I'm just gonna
commit to the method so just dive in
dick and balls and you'll be okay very
nice okay I'm gonna give that a go on my
desk exercise one final thing how do you
choose who sits around the table
that's a good question I think it's it's
the the key domains of your life or like
you could just stop and listen as an
open open listening and be like okay
who's what are the main voices and then
if someone else wants to join as well
you can be like oh yeah yeah sorry we
forgot about you you come and join the
table too just a safety announcement as
well like
if you've got a history of psychosis or
if you feel like there's there's going
to be some dramatic stuff that's bubbled
up then you know do this under the
guidance of a psychotherapist in a safe
environment I've never been a year since
you were working as a doctor and yet the
medical practitioner still
yeah cool okay so I've been flying an
awful lot recently uh which is good I
love adventures and kovid was terrible
for that obviously uh I gave a life hack
I think on the last one which was gate
is it D3 in Amsterdam airport is the
only gate which has seats that don't
have bars in between the seats so you
can go and have a lie down if that is a
brilliant life hack yep that's what
we're here for Peak autism uh now the
there's two here that I'm going to piece
together reason being I have been
completely [ __ ] in the ass a number of
times by the slow Resurgence of capacity
within flights however the unwillingness
of Airlines to reduce down the number of
flights that they send out so this is
just causing delays Across America
anybody that's flown cross-country
within America knows exactly what I'm
talking about flights are being delayed
then they do have some pretty intense
weather which can cause some really huge
problems apparently the main two issues
first one's Pilots but the second one is
the crew of people like the luggage
loaders
um there is just nowhere near enough
staff to deal with the volume people
want to go back on holiday but you can't
just create the staff to give the
capacity for people to go on holiday so
my first uh piece of advice when looking
at flights especially through a site
like Skyscanner which everybody should
be using as a at least a beginning to
have a look at it
reduce the number of connections that
you have in order to stop delays so a
lot of the time you can't go direct but
sometimes you can make a choice between
one and two connections now the one
connection may end up being a little bit
longer a little bit shorter my flight
back to Austin is five minutes longer
despite the fact that it has one fewer
connection when I returned than the
version that I did on the way back the
problem being
the more flights that you rely on the
greater likelihood there is of you
encountering one of those being delayed
which has a knock-on effect to miss the
remainder really really bad idea so just
by reducing that down you reduce your
exposure to different flights like let's
say there's a 10 chance of the flight
being delayed if you go for two instead
of three that's a good idea this also
ties in with another one which is super
important for flying internationally and
I'm using for America specifically pick
flights which immigrate at your
destination if you pick a flight which
enters the country and then you have a
connecting flight from that airport
onward American Immigration specifically
is an absolute pain in the ass and you
will wait and no one is going to help
you're not going to get to the front of
the line because your flight leaves in
two hours that's not the way that it
works you will wait and there will be a
very grumpy looking African-American
woman who does not care about the fact
that you need to leave to get to Miami
or whatever it is uh so those two things
obviously you want to optimize for
what's the best time of departure and
what's the price and if I have upgrades
or if I want to get trades and stuff but
I think reduce connections to avoid
delays and pick flights which immigrate
at the city destination that you're
going to even if you arrive just after a
huge flight got in from Houston or
something like that it doesn't matter
you're at the back of the the queue yeah
it's gonna suck but the degree of
anxiety that you have whilst wondering
am I going to miss my next flight to get
to the next place and then the
downstream impact of that especially if
you're going on holiday you're only on
holiday for seven days or something and
you end up staying over another day uh
yeah those are
that's a really good application of the
broader principle of like don't expect
everything to go smoothly according to
plan because if you line up all of your
dominoes assuming that it's going to go
absolutely textbook
like the same as the reason that Johnny
and I are always late is because we fall
filed to this we assume that there'll be
no traffic on the roads and because once
we made it from our house into the
center of town in seven minutes
no it's not on average it's a 14-minute
journey
let's go
good tips
um
so my so I
uh well because Chris keeps sort of
nudging me to go back onto it keep using
a loop band yeah and I've been back on
it I don't know how long I've been using
it for but I I I I'm always looking for
things that improve my sleep basically
just because that is I'm sure we've all
experienced the like
the night and day difference
when you have a good night's sleep
um I
I think when Yusuf tested them a couple
of years ago I bought some blue blocking
glasses some of the really extreme ones
like the wrap around
um red not not orange seem really
extreme got nothing out of them never
didn't notice any difference not no
changing whoop uh whoop data
then write a lot of stuff online and
Yusuf mentioned about there we go about
um so this might be upsetting for you
Chris Chris has got something that
actually look nice rather than yeah
so you you subtract to a guy who runs a
company that makes these things and
knows all about them and was talking
about how many of these products are
just red plastic and don't actually
block blue light
so I then bought some of some proper
ones and looked into like how do you
validate whether these are legit or not
because you put them on and they kind of
stick they kind of seem different
there's a few tests you can do if you
Google it there's a few tests you can do
where you look at images on screens and
it'll tell you like this should look
like this if it's blocking the blue
light this should look gray they should
look dark
the ones that are actually blue rocking
glasses make such a difference it's
unbelievable like 10 minutes after
putting them on I can feel this like
down regulation and
whoops like 10 increase in Ram when I
wear them wow so getting some proper so
annoying to know that you've been
wasting time with the other ones isn't
it stuff that's pointless walking around
the house looking like an idiot Becca
making fun of me and they just aren't
even doing anything anyway but no it's
going to be mine to you soon man once
once that's the case you can just try
the K now can't you
foreign
in the full biohacking equipment yeah
like Ben Greenfield all the stuff red
glasses on what brands did you end up
going for Johnny
it's the Yusuf knows the name of it I
can't remember the so the the brand is
called block blue light and I can I can
vouch so I've got a kettle that has blue
LEDs when you turn it on and it's it's
bright when you have the glasses on you
can't tell if the kettle's on or not
like it's that powerful so yeah
blue light don't look right to you these
are raw Optics are a Optics owned by a
guy called Matt maruka who's also been
on the show previously uh they do these
which are the yellows and they also do a
red pair I mean these are 300 so
they hopefully they block blue ones he's
mats at the Forefront of of all of this
sort of light and stuff that being said
Andrew huberman ophthalmologist at
Stanford and stuff he is pretty adamant
that blue blocking glasses will maybe
net you small increases but compared
with making sure you get sufficient
sunlight throughout the day including
Early Morning Light than ideally some on
an evening those that's the that's your
Macros and training and wearing blue
blocking like glasses on a night time is
optimizing the creatine dose so making
sure that you're getting sufficient
sunlight exposure because one of the
things that happens especially in the
winter time I learned
if people spend most of their day in
dark rooms looking at screens their
sensitivity to light generally gets
tuned up because they haven't seen any
outdoor light so what you want to try
and do is get it to the stage where your
screen on an evening is a small
percentage of the light that's been
viewed throughout the day at least
that's how I thought it seemed to be
explained to me
so as in you should just use fewer
screens you should get more exposure
today like work in front of a work in
front of a large window ideally where
you can open it at least a little bit
because there's certain types of light
that gets filtered through that yeah I
mean a morning like since I've heard the
Andrew heberman advice on that like it's
such basic things like just go for a
walk first thing in the morning makes
such a difference yeah the the glasses
for me is is like a because in the
evening I imagine you two are probably
the same like I don't really read a book
I'll I'll sit and watch TV generally
like we'll sit and watch a series or
something and I don't really want to
stop that yep so this was a way of like
kind of not making I can I don't quite
feel as bad about it I can still do it
it doesn't seem to impact my sleep well
I think a big part of it at least I
would maybe guess
five percent of the 10 Improvement that
you see will be from the story that you
tell yourself about what watching TV on
an evening time means and how guilty and
the expectation effect but the problem
is expectation effects so robust you
can't get around it by not it that
you're expecting it so you need to do a
thing that you are sufficiently bought
into in order to be able to believe that
it actually works it's just a shame that
the original ones that were far cheaper
that actually didn't block blue light
didn't give me that game
I suppose maybe I had a couple of nights
where it didn't really help and I'm like
oh yeah I've lost my trust in these
stuff but I yeah
digital one
so there's a browser extension called
hush
there's another one called stop the
madness depending on your preference
both of them stop the internet from
being so annoying to use you know when
you go on a website and there's like
five pop-ups you have to accept the
cookies but you can't just accept or
reject you have to go into the like sub
settings and say no no reject or
whatever and then there's like a another
thing and and then you can't click on
this because there's a there's another
Google ad pop-up and it just gets rid of
all the the noise and just allows you to
see what you want to see
on a website and the guy who's designed
it has clearly developed out of pure
Fury
with using annoying websites and he's
really the the guy who wrote stop the
madness is really committed to his
mission so it blocks ads basically or
like anything not just odds it's it's
all the surrounding stuff that so you
know Tom Scott the these like a nerdy
British guy you will have seen him he's
always like this is the most dangerous
Crossing in the UK and I'm out here in
Lancashire and where this has been 34
collisions that so he does all these
kind of like documentary stuff but
um he's got a very good video about why
the internet has become so annoying to
use and a lot of it to do with gdpr and
additional regulation that's not really
practical
by pop-ups and interruptions and that
sort of thing that's interesting that uh
in order to protect
users data they've had to make the user
experience
significantly worse yeah it's a it's a
weird trade-off isn't it
yeah okay so hush I'll stop the madness
extension for Chrome right this is one
that turned into two that turned into
three uh and they're all about Spotify
so
first up is share Spotify podcasts with
the time stamp have you seen this oh no
you not that new so Christian [ __ ] sent
this in about a year ago and I never got
around to using it and yet now it's the
same as copy uh video URL at time from
um YouTube you go on to the use of
proper share function on Spotify for a
podcast you press the share thing and
it'll come up and if you are playing
part way into it it'll say either share
or you can toggle a slider to the side
and say share from time it means that if
you're listening to a section on a
podcast that you absolutely adore you
don't need to screen record it and then
try and send someone the screen
recording you can send them that link
it'll open up in Spotify in app from
WhatsApp or iMessage or whatever and
it'll open at the exact time stamp that
you're talking about so I mean that's
brilliant just great this is what
podcasts are missing because they're not
a social
feature and I think adding in but like I
know there's a few apps that like
snipped and things that are starting to
try and make podcasts social again
but I'm glad that it's become a native
feature as well frankly I think that
audio just continues when it comes to
the reality they just continue to get
eaten alive by video when you can
consume the same content when people can
share a video clip of one of the hacks
that we're talking about here that has
the video how how is it going to be it's
literally just going to be out competed
by the audio version it's always going
to get eaten alive by that so that's the
first one the second one is Spotify for
podcasts generally which has been in an
ongoing discussion between the three of
us for forever we all listen to a lot of
podcasts
um I think me and Johnny were very much
team Apple podcasts for a long time it
was native it allowed a bunch of
different uh like subscriptions it had
pop-ups and notifications that were well
done you had an increased number of
um options through Siri
however
I am of the opinion that Spotify is the
the daddy the king daddy here we go
which I know you said so this is a
repeat this is why I was happy to do
three in a row because I know that
you've already brought this up probably
two years ago but in In fairness though
like whenever I can I will always do my
damnedest to stay within the Apple
ecosystem and I'll try and use Apple
notes and Apple calendar and apple
reminders and it's only when Apple make
it so difficult to stay within that like
apple music and apple podcast they're
just rubbish like any I tried and
Spotify more more people we're over here
yeah don't forget we do this we do this
for a living uh more people are going to
be listening to this right now on Apple
podcasts than on Spotify but every month
the uh not anymore oh yeah well I I
would love to bring people over but the
proportion of people listening on
Spotify is increasing uh month on month
I think that shows like call her daddy
and Rogan have obviously been a big part
of and it was such a smart move
behaviorally let's change people by
forcing them onto the app and then we
need to obviously they have to make sure
that the actual app itself was
sufficiently good but it was
um I mean one of the things that I
really like I I don't like the fact that
you don't have a feed of most recently
up to dated episodes that stood in a
very easy way that was a great element
that Apple podcasts have that I hope
Spotify brings across where you could
just see all of the shows that have most
recently uploaded and then you can
decide oh which one would I like to get
from here it would be great if they
limited the notifications I don't want
to be notified every time that Memphis
May Fire releases a new song but I do
want to be notified every time that
perhaps certain podcasts upload maybe
ones that don't have a regular upload
schedule like Rogan perhaps you know if
it's every Monday Thursday or Saturday
you know there's a modern wisdom episode
but you might Rogan's just sort of
throws them at the wall so like that
would be cool if you could select
particular artists or a podcast and
shows but generally I think the not
without talking too much inside baseball
they've bought anchor they've bought
megaphone they've got the Spotify
advertisers Network they've got a bunch
of things where they've reversed
vertically integrated and forward
vertically integrated themselves into
publishing into buying podcasts outright
and I I think that unless Apple do
something really really really
impressive very quickly
I think well or aggressive because I
think Apple are always trying to like
kick Spotify off aren't they yes well
they had that uh wasn't it Spotify did
an entire campaign about how Apple was
making it uncompetitive for them you
couldn't use Siri and you couldn't use a
bunch of other stuff but if you buy it
yeah that's so annoying but the Spotify
experience in general like take podcasts
away from it just for music their
playlists to discover weekly the release
radar the like collection of the annual
review they give you where they like
tell you what you played yeah like I
have years like going back to like 2015
of like my best of music of each year
like what a great feature I didn't even
make it yeah they just made it for me
let me give you my final bit for Spotify
here so you may or may not have seen
this I use my liked songs quite
frequently main reason being that those
because I'm continuing to update them as
I go they tend to be sort of the ones
that I'm obsessing over right now and
even if I'm listening to an entire album
there'll maybe be one or two songs from
within that album I love now if you go
into your liked songs on Spotify you
will see that there is a little tab at
the very top that says enhance
and if you press enhance it will add
into the playlist of which is completely
chronological it'll just throw in every
other song or every two or three songs
songs that it thinks you should have
liked songs that you're listening to
frequently songs that you you probably
would have liked already and then you
have because that release radar turbo
discover weekly turbo uh kind of I guess
I don't use release radar or discover
weekly so I think that release radar and
discover weekly will probably be songs
that you're not yet familiar with this
liked songs thing is resurfacing songs
that you're continuing to play quite
frequently but haven't yet liked and
sure enough you can go through and you
can press uh I think it's like left
swipe left or right and it either likes
it and keeps it in or you can get rid of
it because it's it you didn't mean to
like it and it wasn't supposed to be
there every single one every single song
that they've put in on enhanced liked
songs playlist has ended up getting a
heart I'm like oh why why is this why is
the new Luke Combs first track on his
album I'm not in there I'm listening to
that all of the time so enhance liked
songs it makes you feel so predictable
yeah when it's like damn it yeah you got
me again there's an extension from that
which is quite similar which is if you
have a playlist that you've made you can
use playlist radio have you used that
before yeah something like that after
you finish an album as well right yeah
so by default but you can force it so if
you go into like your favorites playlist
or whatever or like a best of in the
year it will then just generate things
that are similar to it this is why it's
so good and then it's good for podcasts
as well
difficult to be such a good such a good
app I can't see me ever leaving it yeah
well so that you can't that's the
problem so although they complain up all
the anti-competitive they are
anti-competitive in that you can't
export your podcast selection to another
app so once you're in Spotify
they make it awkward from a from like an
X you can't export XML or whatever of
the things that you've subscribed to or
songs that you've liked maybe they've
changed it recently there's like
third-party apps that will like plug
into your Spotify and you know extract
the data but they make it natively quite
hard
hmm I think that that's probably a
relatively small use case for people
that are using a like VLC media player
custom MP3 traffic code yeah yeah yeah
well it's just if you want to leave
Spotify if you want to use a different
if you were using spotify and you wanted
to go to Apple you have to go in
manually I just subscribe to everything
you don't want to do that the only
people I know that use apple music got
it for free
yeah
the only people I know that's quite
damning isn't it unfortunate Johan what
you got
I have got
um do either of you still use
anything like focus at will or brain FM
or any like focused music
is similar okay do you remember those
I've just got yeah I've got a set of
like uh you know the 10 hour YouTube
videos that are like meditation music
whatever
so I found recently and I did this a
little bit during the pandemic because I
used to work in coffee shops a lot
there's a selection of playlists on
YouTube which is like coffee shop
Ambience with a little bit of jazz and
as though it's raining outside and I try
I tried it and honestly like an hour
later like
oh God where like where I'm just in this
Zone my inbox is empty where have I been
yeah it is you play Coffee Shop music
while you're in the coffee shop like
this while I'm at home it's while I'm at
home okay so it's it's the South it's
like the ambience the Ambiance of a
coffee shop and there's like someone
saying like he can have a of any venti
ladder
including orders yeah yeah yeah no
they're really committed have they got
you were thinking of of uh honestly
coffee yeah the coffee machine going
like the the milk being froth there's a
little bit of jazz and it's raining
outside and you would think that's too
much that would be distracting but
there's something about that obviously
it might just be me but there's
something about them to it yeah yeah but
it's so helpful
so there's a I have the link the actual
link to the one that I use because I'll
just give you that cool that'll be in
the show notes below dude oh yeah
if that's if that's what gets you off
you know if that's I'm just looking
forward to the inbox being like blacking
out and then the inbox being empty yeah
you just see Cafe zero
you said that was it come on I've so
I've got an anti-hack to begin with
which is just a failed so I bought a
homepod mini recently just you reminded
me of it before Johnny
so homepod is Apple's version of a home
speaker it's their version of like the
Alexa speaker or the Google thing wasn't
that burning burning holes onto work
surfaces when it first came yeah it was
it was made of some kind of corrosive
material yeah
sadly it's terrible so I returned it the
same day
so I'll tell you why because currently I
think this was an old life hack from one
of the one of the OG this is a Bose Mini
sound link if it'll come into Focus
there we are
um beautiful speaker incredible bass for
what for the size of it like it's
mind-blowing how they managed it
homepod two trebley not enough thickness
in the base and I am a man that loves
Bassy music
and it uses Wi-Fi protocol not Bluetooth
so it's actually a real fast to get it
to connect to anything and there's about
a two second delay between let's say a
noise happening on your laptop or iPhone
and playing on the speaker which is fine
if you're playing background music but
as soon as you're using it for anything
else it's untenable
and it has to be plugged in so
on all fronts it's it's nice there's a
lot of very
detailed critique of this like you could
this all happened within a couple of
hours
you've used that both sound link or
whatever it's called for a long time
I've got a the anchor version which is
35 pounds I think and the battery on it
is wild I can't believe how loud it is
it goes everywhere it's a good shape as
well you know it's enough to fit in a
laptop bag it's enough to fit in a day
bag or whatever yeah I mean so the
anti-hack was don't buy an Apple home
pod
mini or whatever
and yeah the actual hack is
well the actual hack is completely
separate I just I was just reminded
sneaking in a separate one good good yes
I like it the the hack itself is to get
an instant pot which
I think was recommended by Jordan who
listens to the podcast incredible an
instant pot is a multi
function thing that you put in your
kitchen it does slow cooking it does
pressure cooking it Cooks rice and you
can get a one with a special laser that
does air frying as well
so really it replaces the need for any
other thing in your kitchen
so particularly if you live in like a
studio apartment in Tokyo or something
and you you just want something that's
very space efficient
but where it really comes into shine is
you can put a whole chicken into it with
some white wine and rosemary
and it pressure Cooks it within 20-25
minutes it's falling off the bone like
it's deliciously tender and the way that
pressure cooking works is that it
infuses the flavor into the meat so a
bit of white wine and rosemary It'll
like push that flavor into the the very
it'll really penetrate that chicken into
the fibers oh in the fibers yeah so like
chefs really like pressure cooking
because of that reason the only downside
is that it doesn't make very aesthetic
food like pressure cooked foods not it
just looks like a stew
so
it's all about taste does it smell
because one of the product problems that
you have with airfryers especially if
you do it with meat it
it's like a a hair dryer
blowing the smell
cooking crispy chicken around your
kitchen
so I can't speak for air frying but with
pressure cooking no because the the way
that it works is the field it plugs yeah
so it plugs it and seals it however
when it's finished you've got two
choices you can either let it the
pressurized on its own which takes an
hour or so or you can take it outside
don't do it inside because that's where
you basically atomizing the the smell
um Take It Outside flip the switch and
it just goes
for about three minutes oh okay and
that's a specific that's an actual
uh that's not you Jerry rigging it and
just ripping the lid off and being hit
oh got hit in the face by 500 PSI of
cooked chicken yeah I I think if you
were to try and rip off the lid it would
be really dangerous like it would
probably bad things would happen
hospitalization yeah fine right that's
have you got you must have a
slow cooker of some kind Johnny
I don't
it's a surprise yeah I'm a fan of us I'm
a fan of a slow cooker I've not had a a
pressure cooker before but well a
pressure cooker is just fast slow
cooking
good point slow cooking on three times
speed yeah good point actually that's
another thing uh that I haven't uh
mentioned about the difference in
podcast players Spotify has way more
options for fine tuning the speed one
1.2 1.5 1.8 to 2.5 and 3. I think it
goes up to four uh so whereas with apple
it's just it's just not got it just not
good at Apple but if you want to do
modern wisdom on uh new and noteworthy
please feel free to get that on
mine which has just been reminded by
what you were saying Johnny
there is an option now when you have air
pods
on iPhone called background sounds are
you familiar with this
no oh so what Apple has decided to do is
it's realized that a lot of people need
not just uh
sound dampening or like the um noise
cancellation on the outside they
actually have and let me see if I can
put this up to here so come on
you'll see that there's this little ear
thing here if you press that it pops up
and says background sounds and
background sounds
so that's ocean
and there is balance noise bright noise
dark noise ocean rain and stream
so basically with this how the [ __ ] do I
turn it off there we go uh this is
inbuilt Apple certified background sound
now the great thing that you can do
about this is you can have two volumes
set for it how much of the volume that
is on at the moment when nothing else is
playing do you want the background
sounds to be at
and then a second volume which is when
you are playing something else
how much of the total overall volume
that's available that is relative to
what's playing do you want the
background sound to be at use case
number one I am by the pool in a lovely
Resort in Tulum Mexico I am listening to
some cool podcasts that I was enjoying I
think Tim Dylan on Rogan but there's a
crying child uh it was actually a crying
child with special needs but crying
Child near the pool I didn't want to
hear the sound of this child anymore uh
no matter how much noise cancellation I
had on had I have decided to go so loud
on Rogan and Tim it would have been
pretty uncomfortable so background
sounds came on low level only 10 10 but
that fills in the gap of the background
you've still got noise cancellation and
then coming through over the top you've
got the podcast pretty pointless for
listening to music along with it reason
being that music tends to fill those
spaces in any case but for audibling uh
when you've got a noisy surrounding and
you're trying to focus on listening to
great and then also when there's nothing
you're on a plane you haven't had your
white noise playlist from Spotify
downloaded for offline or whatever
pretty robust the waves or whatever that
was ocean one is high quality it's the
sound of waves coming over it goes up
and down it's active but not too active
they've got the white the balance the
brown the pink noise they've got a rain
one I mean it's Apple you know like
they're gonna get it right
that is a good one they're always adding
different like there's that feature on
airpods where have you seen it where
like if you look to the right of the
life it still sounds like
yeah
that's crazy that that caught me once
when I was crossing the road I was
listening to like a a video on my
airpods in my pocket and I looked left
and I was like oh my God
[Laughter]
luckily that wasn't
wow
okay Johnny what do you got okay
uh which one should I do
I am gonna do
the this was recommended to me by a
client so it is a Chrome extension
for all of the I don't know whether it's
all of them but there's a load of
visualized value
uh diagrams on every new tab that you
open in Chrome so
it's just something that I visualize
value I tend to use this very behind it
do you are you familiar with that Chris
Jack's
even better then everyone will be
familiar with that so it's something
that I've been like always wanting to
learn more about or see more examples of
because every diagram that I see every
drawing that I see is like it's so
cleverly articulating this idea but I
just don't know I didn't have a way to
get more exposure to them but I had so
many
like Content ID ideas email ideas
um reminders of Concepts that you forget
it's like it's like a read wise in some
ways like a like just a gentle reminder
of like oh yeah was it maybe yeah by
visualized value it must have been don't
know I don't know but it's just every
new type is a visualized value graphic
what's your favorite concept that you've
been reminded of recently can you think
of any
hmm
a lot of them are to do with like
it sounds morbid but reminders of death
it does sound a bit morbid mate not
gonna lie like but you know what I mean
though they're not like that I feel like
the majority are like about compounding
and building leverage with digital
products and stuff but you've gone
straight many about death frankly you
know the idea of like you
um that not not just thinking about
death in general but like the stoic idea
of thinking about death and how things
are finite and it will end soon
um there's a there's a few that have
come out lately they've been like that
that I always think I should think more
about that and give that more you know
momentum more I should spend more of my
more of my living days thinking about my
death yeah so I I really strongly think
that to be honest I think it was it a
good stoic a good stoic Spends His Life
preparing to die so that when he dies he
doesn't fear it some something like that
why do where'd you get this is it just
visualized value it's just in in Chrome
just go into extensions and search
visualize value and I'll be there
Chrome extension very nice Yusuf
Apple reminders or tick tick and
presumably things and any task
management app
will have
any app worth it sold will have a
feature where you can ping a reminder
based on your location
so typically used for when I'm leaving
the house it goes I'll remember your
wallet or whatever
I use it as part of a social list for
whenever I enter a 30 mile radius of
Edinburgh or London or Leeds to get in
touch with certain people because what
you don't want what you're avoiding here
is visiting London then on your way back
someone goes oh you're in London how
come you didn't get in touch with me and
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah I should have
gone for coffee with them
so it's having a location-based reminder
whenever you enter a certain Zone and
particularly useful for Eucharist I
guess where you've got pros in several
area codes
dude I like that I think that's cool do
you remember Facebook used to have a
function that was exactly the same
such and such is near you
is nearby it's quite a creepy function
yeah but you could select it on and off
if you didn't want to uh
but yeah reminders does the like when
you're messaging someone I've used that
quite a few times it's like when you
open iMessage and go to message someone
uh yeah the reminder pops up then and
what what's it or like what's a use case
for that so like so you need to
tomorrow afternoon you you need to
remember to message someone about
something for example so if you were on
your phone and you you thought well you
find yourself in a conversation with
someone and you remember the thing that
you were going to talk to them about it
pops up then so it's like a person
contextual yeah I suppose Apple's trying
to create this like oh like you open a
link and it says Ah Johnny sent you this
or but the Apple also has find my
friends feature the reason I'm not super
on board for that is that that requires
you both to have a live location tracker
at all times
yeah not everyone's going to be happy
with just always sharing their their
location with their friends no probably
not
uh right okay so this is I haven't got a
car in Austin I have been
single-handedly keeping Uber solvent uh
for the last few months uh first up is
Uber one which is their Uber premium
thing I think I mentioned this last time
but in case you haven't done Uber one's
great it works similar to Amazon Prime
you get multiple types of benefits it
works on ubereats it also works on Uber
you get five percent off everything then
some preferential delivery sometimes you
get quicker pickups sometimes you get
free upgrades I think that Uber one also
allows you to
get more options of the cars presets
have you ever got into a car and it says
what sort of level of talkativeness do
you want the the driver to have what
sort of climate do you want you want a
cool hot colds whatever so Uber one is
is part of that
um second one is Uber instead of cars
especially if you're spending a good bit
of time in a city and you're going away
a lot of the time you might consider I'm
going to rent a car because I'm going to
be driving around a lot if you actually
look at the cost of ubering everywhere
for a day it does not come in anywhere
close to how much renting a car would be
especially if it's lots of small
Journeys and if it's over a longer
period of time one thing that I've
realized is obviously
on the days that I'm not ubering I'm not
paying for anything on the days that I
have a car but don't use it I still pay
for the car that being said I've missed
driving so like way more than I thought
I would and I knew I loved driving got
back here jumped in my car took a little
while to start up given it hasn't been
driven for six months but just felt so
great to be back driving I really enjoy
it uh he is the one which was very
interesting and I learned this from a
driver that was stopping so that I could
collect something from the supermarket
Uber doesn't get paid for stopping
so the way that your Uber drivers get
paid is based on the feed that you are
that they're proposed at the very very
beginning so
if you get in a car and it's nine
dollars or whatever it is in their
interests to get you there as quickly
and in the most efficient route possible
if you're stuck in traffic you don't
need to be particularly concerned but it
just always wondered that it changes for
me at least it changes the uh Power
Dynamic a little bit and also the fear
around whether this guy is taking the
pace or whatever else it might be
um and also if you're stopping to pick
somebody up and you're putting multiple
destinations in you're stopping on route
knowing that they don't get paid for
stopping is from a courtesy perspective
for you and the the driver a pretty
important thing to know because after
two minutes they can only stop for two
minutes the reason for that is that
they're not getting paid for this so
it's in their interests for you to move
quickly and if you want them to get you
there on time and all the rest of it I
think that it's a pretty good courtesy
thing to keep your Uber drivers happy
that you don't dick about when they're
Stood Still
so there's no way for the Uber driver to
take the mech but like in a London card
like the driver if you don't know the
area the driver could take you a really
Wiggly way around the destination or
stop for ages and so with Uber that's
transferred entirely onto the the
customer
in the if the customer's like oh can we
just pull up here and pick up my mate or
whatever yes yeah yeah yeah well the
stops and stuff need to be really should
just be put in the app uh and obviously
everybody should know this but you can
have multiple destinations put into so
if you're going to go and pick somebody
up it's not like you need to get in and
then ask him you can actually place that
into the app and have multiple
destinations go the way it's like when
you're sharing an Uber back with someone
to drop you both off at both at each of
your houses and then
on the way one of them says oh I want to
go to McDonald's and so you add that in
and then that becomes part of part of
the round trip that sounds like a
familiar memory to me
yeah it might have happened to me at
some point in that instance if you
extend the journey they still don't get
anything what do you not know no of
course you do yeah because you'll have
to they do because yeah even if you
travel even if you just say stop on
Route it'll add a 50p on or something
okay
um but for the two minute stop yep
precisely
I've just remembered I think one of the
original podcasts probably 2015 2016.
where we were talking about accidentally
pressing a uber XL or whatever it's
called Uber premium thing yeah and then
you just hear like in the background oh
[ __ ] like you've been charged for 10 000
Dirhams on a [ __ ] helicopter okay
well let's I think I've still got loads
in the tank however we usually finish
these off by talking about what we've
been watching
recently if we've been watching anything
good Netflix Amazon Prime hboe Apple
eats suggestions
um
I'm just going to get it out there right
wasn't impressed with Lord of the Rings
I agree very much uh first two episodes
was recording this after the first two
episodes were up wasn't particularly
impressed uh Elon Musk tweeted today
saying uh uh J.R.R Tolkien is turning in
his grave He also mentioned that the
only male character that isn't uh stupid
or narcissistic and is brave kind
incompetent is like one guy uh and it
does seem to be a very female powered
show the moment not that there's
anything particularly wrong with that
but it was kind of confusing I don't
really understand what's going on
not that impressed of you just not very
good have you watched it yeah
what do you think she's not very just
didn't really enjoy it
don't think I'll finish it
half a billion they paid for that show
250 million was just for the license
no I mean they were they were set up to
for it to be disappointing really
weren't they like it for it to carry
that brand and impress everybody it's a
hard thing to do I don't think they've
done even accounting for that I don't
think they've done a very good job but I
think they had a very hard yeah remix
what about what about the new Game of
Thrones there it is there it is
have you watched it Seth you're watching
new Game of Thrones
no I I only watched
the first episode back in 2013 when I
was recovering from testicle surgery and
so I wasn't in a great mood and I just
couldn't I couldn't get into it
out there with a lot of opioids in my
system just like I imagine you're
listening going like me too man me too
that was my experience with Game of
Thrones uh what do you think Johnny
because we were both pretty big fans of
Game of Thrones I thought it was I
thought the first episode especially was
fantastic
I I was a little disappointed with the
second episode I thought that was a
little slow not slow yeah just generally
it's okay they're obviously leaning into
the sort of political side of things
here was here's my bro science theory
around it you remember when you were
watching Harry Potter as a kid or
reading Harry Potter and in the first
book they were really big into the house
points and then my sort of book three he
was breaking people out of
um out of jail but it was still like
bothered about what was going on in
school and then by book Seven he's
trying to save the world right my point
being that the way that most of these
series they continue to scale the
intensity and the the Grandeur of the
challenges that the protagonists have to
face now the problem that you had with
Game of Thrones at the beginning it's
like here's something happening in
Winterfell and blah blah blah and then
by the end of the season they've got to
save the world
especially being a prequel especially
only being 170 years before the ACT
actions of the next one and also knowing
that there is a kind of a limited
timeline between the two of them there
is an upper bound on how much growth and
scale that they can't go and fight White
Walkers or wage a war because that's not
part of the law of this world so they're
having to lean in a little bit more to
the politics of what's going on within
the show which is great and the politics
side was interesting and exciting but I
don't know they're just the the
The Field's missing meat to me a little
bit also in not a lot of sex
no and again with this not a massive
amount of sort of compelling male
protagonists that there's no guys there
that I'm really rooting for at the
moment and I don't actually know if I'm
rooting for any of the girls either yet
so all in all
not that much of a fan
a fan like in waiting but again it's
because the bar was set so high I felt
so in love with the with the Game of
Thrones up until the final season but it
it felt similar to me to like a Casino
Royale change in the bond
switch Yeah like bit more basic I know
there's dragons in it still but it's a
bit more basic there's a there's a few
like the jousting scenes like very like
gritty and real
which it didn't really feel like it
happened in the like a lot of the the
last season of The Game of Thrones and
things as you say everything's very
Grand huge battles going on lots of CGI
that was just two guys two nights on
horses in a Arena I just thought that
was quite cool it was a bit of a change
of Direction but I do know what you mean
what have you been watching anything
else that you liked
I have been watching something called
The Suspect
on ITV I think there's only two
uh episodes of it but
really good
so far it's like a psychological
Thriller
um whereas like a guy
he's a psychiatrist and he becomes the
this suspect in a in a case
um
phenomenal so far but it's one of those
things that they release weekly and it's
so and you really just you want it all
to be on
available to watch to finish it might
get might get terrible
releasing two episodes on the first day
was Bloody smart I'll give them that
yeah don't open with one episode
I'm just adding the suspect to my list
which is a a life hack that we're all
all on board with where you have a list
of shows that to watch and you put the
person's name who recommended it next to
it for accountability consequences
I imagine you have an external
spreadsheet with a rating system of
whether or not you should how highly you
should trust that person's suggestions
yeah you see you have a coefficient for
each person depending on their kind of
ongoing ranking and uh Johnny is
actually winning am I really
yeah that's great have you have you
watched anything recently I actually
watched I think it was your
recommendation Chris the boys oh
wow
so I've just finished the third season
oh very that's a 30-hour commitment that
is a
about it's taken a few months that's
about as good of a
command Commendation as you can give I
think oh yeah for me to go home run with
it is yeah and it's great it's a really
really nice concept really well executed
as well and I think sometimes when you
see I have shows like that where
someone to explain it on paper you'd be
like oh yeah that sounds like a
brilliant idea to flesh out and then it
falls flat on the on the delivery but
this was great on both sides so yeah
really good glad you I try to finish it
I tried it no I tried it actually come
on come on I feel like I need I tried
like Game of Thrones I had to try three
or four times before I got into it same
with peaky blinders same with Breaking
Bad
so I probably need another government
you're not an easy easy check to please
that's I think I just needed that I I am
very like if I'm halfway through the
first episode and I don't like something
that'll turn off okay I'm not watching
it yeah it's worth sticking up one more
recommendation that's a bit it's more
just that it's because it's unbelievable
it's based on the truth is it's called
like the thief
his wife and the canoe or something like
that I think it's on BBC it's on BBC or
ITV one of the two I wasn't intending to
say this but it's based on this it's a
true story about that guy in like Seton
Carew who
was it was going to claim bankruptcy so
just just paddle that sea in a canoe and
then claimed they died and hid in the
next door house for two years and his
wife claimed life insurance and got all
the money and like this series if it
wasn't based on truth the things that
unfolded it you'd be like this is
ridiculous like who's made this plot but
it's all factual so is this dramatized
or a documentary it's drama It's a drama
of what happens there's bits of it that
are slightly exaggerated
um but like these two like tell their
kids tell their family that this guy's
dead then he's just
and because they've all got Geordie
accents so he's just like oh well I'll
live next door and no no no no
so that that reminds me of that out of
the stuff that's like you hear the first
thing and you're like surely not and
then it gets more and more ridiculous
you recommended the
the one about the woman that set up the
vegan restaurants and she met this guy
who said bad vegan yeah and he was a bit
of a catfish so I think for anyone who
enjoyed that there's a couple of podcast
series one of them is called sweet Bobby
which is the most turbo Catfish story
that I've ever heard it's a journalistic
um True Crime thing where they they
follow through the story and there's I
think each episode is 25 minutes seven
episodes so it's short and sweet if
you've got a long car Journey or
something coming up definitely get on to
that
um and the other one is called call
Bethel a little bit more heavy it's
about the systematic sexual abuse in the
Jehovah's Witness community
pretty sounds pretty intense yeah
um but for something a bit more
light-hearted a fantastic fungi
it's a podcast series or TV uh
documentary so it's
just about funky as a as a thing not
just
hallucinogenic ones but how they how
they exist it sounds like a really dry
boring thing but it's so visually
beautiful is it Paul stamina
he's on there as well yeah because he's
the other guy Elementary I think called
how to change your mind which is on
Netflix the documentary about that yeah
Paul's just like the Mushroom Man isn't
he the mushroom yeah he he knows his
stuff the only thing that he's like
well that a lot of the people on there
are like I have been studying fungi for
the last 12 years and it's like you know
when someone's an expert in something
and they they just decide to pronounce
the thing a bit differently to make them
seem like a special expert even though
yeah uh I watched Untold
have you seen these yes
Mante Teo
oh Seth this is I would say that this is
especially because you like the catfish
things I would bump this
I really don't want my coefficient to
drop but I would I would guess I would
be prepared to wage a large amount of
money that you will very much enjoy this
it's a two-part documentary series about
an American football player uh who gets
catfished online and they tell the story
from his side from the catfish's side
from the side of his coaches and he's
super famous he was going to be the
number one draft pick one year and just
all hell breaks loose uh and the person
that was catfishing him at the time
identified as male now identifies as a
woman and uh it is
it's very compelling and it's very well
done the thing that I liked the most
about it was uh Mante Teo the athlete
and the protagonist his attitude I think
he's just a total hero of a guy like
very into Faith very into hard work just
accepted the fact that he'd messed up
the entire world was laughing at him
people were going out on um Halloween
nights out in America uh Mante Teo and
his girlfriend and it was then with
their arm around no one and this guy
just continued to take it on the chin
continue to try and perform uh he's just
he's he's great so I highly reckon
that's exciting so I've I've put that
high up on the list so now currently in
the the leaderboard between you both
we've got whiplash from Miles Invasion
from Johnny
uh Untold from Eucharist and then we've
got ex machina the alpinist and the
suspect in that order so I would get rid
of invasion just get rid of invasion to
delete it yeah okay because that was a
Johnny ex machina stick that up there
that's great
I'm happy for my game to go next to the
Monte Toyota one yeah well that's double
coefficient yeah beautiful oh wow you're
not taking any of my scores Johnny this
is my well no it's more just that I
think it forces him to watch it first
doesn't it yeah but you're also going to
benefit to get the credit for it and
that's gonna but I also hit myself up
like I'm the person with the the
antonish record here like I'm in the
lead I I just sounded enough if I can
slip stream and hang on to the coattails
of your fantastic suggestions
Soviet look Gentlemen let's leave it
there uh everybody that is listening
what should they check out of what you
guys have to offer have you got anything
new or cool that's available online we
have a so it's a we have an updated
version of the same thing that's even
better so we help the majority of what
we do these days is we help coaches
mainly personal trainers anyone in the
fitness and health space move their
service online so we just teach what we
did in propane Fitness so there's a
training that explains 90 of that for
free at propanefitness.com forward slash
modern wisdom
If instead you just like some Fitness
stuff so like a training program some
macros you can go to propanefitness.com
we have a free calculator on that it'll
give you some macros give you some
calories
those are two places and we're also on
YouTube podcasts social media
Tick Tock these days very modern bloody
everywhere trendy can't get rid of you
uh well look I will be doing a
post-wedding uh update I'm sure for
everyone uh after your ceremony your
nuptials this Friday uh which I'm very
much looking forward to uh are you gonna
drink scone
no sadly
what you've decided in advance
what's the thinking yeah it's just
well there was no thinking behind
drinking so
that's like saying what's what's the
thinking behind like not putting
smearing poo on your face when you get
to the wedding what about if I if I if I
devote like if I spent 500 pounds on
drinks that were just for you
and no one else could drink them and in
a speech you were like oh everyone give
a big hand to use it yeah
it's over The Far Side
everybody is not allowed to go to it
except for Yusuf uh so you really
twisting my nipples yeah it happens when
it's Unstoppable Force immovable object
does yourself have a beer
I'm looking forward to seeing you both
uh everything from propane Fitness
propanefitness.com modern wisdom and all
the rest of the stuff will be in the
show notes below as well and that's it
until next time gentlemen goodbye
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]